Доброго дня шановні колеги Доброго дня
шановні українці сьогодні Україна веде
Війну за виживання Росія хоче стерти з
лиця землі не тільки наші міста і села
Росія хоче знищити нашу надію і віру в
краще майбутнє Тому зараз у час
повномасштабної війни ми розуміємо
важливість розвитку і трансформації
Української освіти та медицини це база
успішної держави це основа для відбудови
та нашого прогресу цього року видатки
бюджету на освіту складуть більш ніж 170
Гринь це зростання на понад 20 млрд
грвень порівняно з минулим роком виплати
українським освітянам нашим вчителям
будуть підвищені на 21% ми виділяємо
суттєві кошти 2,5 млрд грвень на
облаштування укриттів 1,5 млрда грвен на
нову українську школу 1, млрда гривень
на модернізацію шкільних їдалень і 1
млрд грвень на шкільні автобуси цьогоріч
Ми також плануємо запустити масштабну
реформу вищої освіти насамперед мова про
про зміну підходів фінансування зараз у
системі вищої освіти є навчання на
бюджеті і за контрактом ми пропонуємо
змінити такий підхід або охопити
державною підтримкою якнайбільше
студентів сьогодні ухвалюємо
законопроект який передбачає що в
майбутньому студенти зможуть навчатись
за рахунок державного замовлення
державних грантів пільгових кредитів а
також на контрактній формі навчання
державне замовлення - це повністю
безоплатне навчання студента за бюджетні
кошти можливість безоплатно навчатись
надаватиметься найкращим за конкурсним
балом вступникам також частину бюджетних
місць буде надано вразливим категоріям
державне замовлення стосуватиметься
передусім спеціальностей які потрібні
державі наприклад суспільству потрібні
вчителі та лікарі тому держава буде
повністю оплачувати навчання для
найкращих вступників за цими
спеціальностями а після успішного
випуску пропонуватиме перше робоче місце
Одночасно ми запроваджуємо модель
державних грантів які дозволять повністю
або ча во покрити витрати на навчання ці
гранти не треба буде повертати вони не
передбачають жодних зобов'язань щодо
відпрацювання на розмір гранту буде
впливати два критерії перший - це
результати зовнішнього оцінювання знань
другий - це обрана спеціальність хоча
сума гранту не обов'язково покриматиме
повну вартість навчання але кількість
вступників які отримують фінансову
підтримку суттєво збільшиться за рахунок
більш справедливого розподілу такої
підтримки так сього ні у нас 60%
студентів навчається на контракті наша
мета щоби 60% студентів отримували різні
види державної підтримки держзамовлення
гранти ваучери або в майбутньому
пільгові кредити важливо що ця нова
система буде поширюватися лише на нових
вступників серед новацій які ми також
пропонуємо це встановлення спеціальних
умов прийому на навчання в університетах
для наших ветеранів дітей загиблих
українських героїв дітей з інвалідністю
дітей сирі та інших пільгових категорій
вища освіта має стати більш якісною і
більш доступною для тих хто цього дійсно
прагне цього року ми підвищуємо
фінансування не лише освіти але і
медицини видатки на охорону здоров'я
загалом складуть 239 млрд грвен що на 31
млрд більше ніж минулого року на
програму медичних гарантій додаємо 16
млрд грн запускаємо пілотний проект
безкоштовного зубопротезування для
ветеранів 1 млрд грвень виділяємо на
облаштування укриттів та безпечних умов
у лікарнях продовжуємо робити медицину
більш доступною та якісною незалежно від
того де проживає людина зокрема значну
увагу буде будемо приділяти фінансуванню
реабілітації охороні материнства та
дитинства діагностиці та лікуванню раку
програму доступні ліки теж збільшуємо до
5,2 млрд грн про продовжимо розвиток
цифрових інструментів вже найближчим
часом плануємо запустити електронний
кабінет пацієнта в ньому українці
зможуть самостійно змінювати персональні
дані та керувати деклараціями з
сімейними лікарями і надалі будемо
підвищувати ефективність медичних
закупівель ми запровадили зміни які
передбачають що медичні заклади купують
ліки та медичні вироби через так званий
електронний каталог це сприяло значній
економії коштів а також пришвидшило
процедури закупівлі сього сьогодні
Приймемо Постанову що передбачає
розширення переліку ліків і медвиробів
які будуть купуватись через такий
каталог ці зміни важливі бо це про
прозорість та про ефективність
використання коштів платників податків
саме таку державу ми будуємо в усіх
сферах ефективну прозору цифрову це
потрібно аби забезпечити перемогу це
потрібно для того аби стати членом
Європейського Союзу Дякую за увагу Слава
Україні Слава